three two one
[Music]
oh my god how good is it
isn't this awesome
what is that uh that's bindi irwin's
terrifying surprise nursery courtesy of
her little brother
robert irwin it was just amazing
on thursday morning a sneak peek clip
from bindi and her husband
chandler powell's upcoming discovery
plus special crikey it's a baby aired on
good morning america
grace feels so lucky to get a standing
ovation for being born
how special is this in the sweet video
the pair introduces their newborn baby
girl to the staff at the australia zoo
where they both
work sorry so this is grace warrior
irwin powell
she is gorgeous seven pounds seven
ounces
20 inches long and just perfect in every
way
i think my first words were that she was
our graceful warrior
yeah and we just went that's that's her
name
that is perfect so we we decided that
that grace was really special and then
her two middle names are warrior irwin
as a tribute to dad of course
bindi is the daughter of the late steve
irwin
dad is and always will be my living
breathing superhero
and bindi's brother surprises her with a
very scary dinosaur themed nursery
that features a massive t-rex replica
three two one
[Music]
oh my god how good is it
isn't this awesome
what is that it's the look on bindi's
face
for me as a family we are quite a we're
a wild family
it's bruce it's bruce the the biggest
dinosaur
attack of my life initial reaction from
bindi she's speechless pretty great
she can't even articulate how much she
loves it
when she grows up with bruce she won't
be afraid of anything exactly
she'll be so happy so it's not clear if
the family keeps the nursery as
is but bindi did share a sweet pastel
animal-themed nursery wall on instagram
back in january
which was a lot more furry woodling
creature and a lot
less jurassic park we're really thrilled
bindi and chandler welcome to their
sweet bundle of joy in march
and since then the new parents have been
soaking up time with their little girl
and have their hands full literally
it's amazing we are just so thrilled
we're just over the moon
on wednesday the proud dad shared this
sweet snap of his wife of one year
and their newborn grace as well as their
dog
piggy the caption family photo
you know we've been together almost six
years and from the moment i met bendy i
knew she was the perfect girl in my life
the one
you